[Music]
you give an organization 12 years now
yeah so you've known better than anybody
this is a game of statistics your
batting average just isn't where it
needs to be there's always next year
sorry coming home was in Brampton I must
have given some thought into life after
baseball you can do what mom never had a
back-up plan
so if you let your friends know that
you're back home no I told you talk to
him in a long time
can't quit you're the best baseball
player that ever came out of this town
you remember my high school girlfriend
rachael kinley
how long are you home for it I bought a
one-way ticket I mean we haven't spoken
in years is it impossible to consider
that maybe I've moved on
[Music]
nothing to show for the last 12 years
that just feels like everyone else is
moving on and I'm just stuck in the same
place you know what I mean so I would
this is Eddie this is the guy Rachel
Stan nice to meet you actually we're
engaged Eddie proposed to me this
morning and you said what are you doing
here to tell you how it's gonna go
Oh what's getting my life how your
life's gonna go I don't have time for
this I just got engaged
I can tell you baby
I'm not good enough to make it in the
place I want to be when you never
appreciated the journey but this at the
end of the day we all end up in the same
place
you broke up with me remember you
wouldn't wait any longer have done the
breaking up and it was because I was so
tired of you choosing the game over
[Music]
you're incapable of just having a little
taste and you would keep chasing it and
then we're gonna be back where we were
three years ago
so then I don't strike out keeps tapping
on the shoulder yeah he does that you
get him to stop victory
you